Chris waters here with a GameSpot news
update new screenshots of the Xbox one
and PlayStation 4 versions of Minecraft
show a big improvement in draw distance
over last generation consoles in a
Twitter post 4j Studios the developer
responsible for the console versions of
Minecraft tweeted out a series of
screenshots primarily as a means for
demonstrating the improved view distance
they're currently working on the Xbox
360 and ps3 have a very abrupt end to
the visible world the new consoles are
able to improve upon that aspect and
give a significantly longer view the
developer previously announced that due
to save size limits there will still not
be infinite worlds they recently
provided an update with encouraging news
saying we're currently trying out a
world size increase of 36 times the area
of the Xbox 360 and ps3 world no release
dates have been announced but a recent
report said the release for the Xbox one
version was close to being finalized
while the ps4 version along with the
Vita version is expected out no later
than September both the ps4 and Xbox one
versions will allow for save files from
the ps3 and 360 versions respectively to
carry over we'll keep you updated with
any new minecraft announcements right
here on GameSpot
[Music]